jane inter si vous aimez vous a fait
faire une séance de voyage de voyance un
petit peu spécial on va démarrer
benjamin castaldi maxime ekedi regarder
en fait ils pensent que c'est une séance
de voyance normale et à la fin ils se
rendent compte que c'est encore un coup
de barre
[Musique]
bonjour monsieur jo savez-vous jour
c'est bien les pieds comme moi imaginez
qui a des racines d'accord qui sordo au
total on a eu beaucoup de chefs toujours
un peu d'appréhension mais de quoi
l'écosystème autour enfin petit exercice
pour vous détendre
d'accord vous avez tapé d'un moment
allez-y les process et dire oui oui on
tape dans les mains ce qu'il ya une star
quelqu'un de connu et qui voulait
rentrer en contact autre quelqu'un
décéder bon jusqu'au bout après celle de
savoir s'ils ont apprécié ces notes il
irait à part de ces bourses tard c'est
donc à yves montand au choix vous avez 2
2 2 tab les le choix de roi puisque
moyenne stars en vue mais c'est plutôt
une star américaine qui est décédé moi
j'aurais tué charlot à côté vous jure je
charlie chaplin qui essayent de rentrer
en contact avec vous ou le conte parle
de quoi et j'aimerais vraiment savoir
s'il m'a remparts et de l'attraction qui
va s'appliquer légende
parce que j'aimerais beaucoup mais je
vous jure que je présente à monsieur je
suis sincère on va taper dans les mains
s'il vous plaît
compote tape dans les mains on frotte et
après on dit oui à frapper dans dix huit
très fort oui oui oui oui oui oui
alors maintenant je vais établir votre
rapport à que les éléments à chaque fois
je prends une carte vous allez dire très
fort j'aime ce que vous allez voir
détendez vous
[Musique]
l'ajam le feu j'aime ma femme vous vous
en voyez
j'aime l'eau
[Musique]
j'aime la terre j'aime ma terre
si vous avez je vais mourir
j'aime la terre plus fort j'aime la
terre battue si j'ai pas il faut le dire
vraiment sympa
non j'aime pas légion pas la terre moi
j'ai besoin d'entendre j'aime la terre
voire bit le plus fort bien mais pas la
terre de mes lauriers des âmes l'accueil
se passait rien à ces montants seront
équipés des caches ta mère
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]